- Hi everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our daily livestream.
For those of y'all who are
wondering what this is,
this is something we
started several months ago
as a way to keep us all connected
during times of social distancing
and just having interesting guests,
and have interesting conversations
and take your questions
and today like always,
I'll be taking your questions
on Facebook or on YouTube
and we have team members who can surface
what y'all are asking.
We're going to do a last minute change
to today's livestream because
of all that's going on
in the world.
We originally had one of
our great team members Marta
who's our VP of engineering
scheduled to join,
but given what's going on in the world,
I thought it'd be better to save Marta
for a day where there
isn't all of this going on.
And you know, I just wanna
give my two cents here
for whatever it's worth.
A lot of times, I'm very
careful about saying
Khan Academy, and it's true.
We are not a political organization.
We as an organization are
not left, we are not right,
we are just trying to
empower as many people
in the world to have
access to an education
and I think every now and then,
there's an issue that comes up
that frankly transcends politics
and I think that what's going on right now
with obviously what happened George Floyd,
but obviously that's just one
in a string of many incidents
where there is really
only one side to this
in that there's just
some basic human dignity
that isn't being given to folks.
And you know, sometimes you
can rationalize that well,
the whole world there's going
to be things that happen
that are unfortunate but for
every one of these things
that captures folks' attention
that gets captured on
someone's cell phone,
you've got to imagine
that there's another 100
or another thousand that
don't get the attention
and don't get captured.
And for every time something
horrible like this happens
that someone gets killed
or severely injured,
you have to imagine that
there's another thousand times
that it doesn't quite get that far,
but someone is humiliated or
someone is unjustly imprisoned
or just treated in an inhumane way.
And this is a real thing.
This isn't just something
that happens on the news.
I remember when I was in business school,
this was back in 2003, one of
my classmates, Matt Turner,
I know he's written about this
so he probably wouldn't
mind me mentioning his name,
who's African American.
He was section president,
he was an air force captain,
he had gone with me to MIT,
he was clearly at Harvard business school
and he was visiting some friends in Dallas
and while he was visiting,
he was just walking on the street
and all of the sudden, a
police helicopter and cops,
policemen started showing up with guns out
and he was arrested for an hour
and frankly humiliated and it turns out
that the crime he was a suspect for
was committed by four white
men several miles away.
And that was the first time
that it was an aha in my mind
that this is not something
that is just an abstract thing
that happens in random parts of, you know,
places that are disconnected.
They can happen to your friends,
they can happen to your family,
they can happen to people you care about
and if it happens to someone like Matt,
who is by any measure as kind of living
the aspirational life that we,
or what we should aspire to I should say,
and has served for our military,
doing everything right on the.
If he gets humiliated like that,
you can imagine what happens to folks
that have a less of a
voice, less of a platform,
less representation.
So this is a really huge thing.
All of us at Khan Academy,
we pride ourselves
that we wanna help
level the playing field.
We wanna make sure that everyone
can tap into their potential.
But if you don't have human dignity,
if you have to worry about your own safety
just because of the color of your skin,
because of the way you might look,
I think that just hampers
your ability to have
an openness to anything
else, to be able to engage
in your education or your
career or whatever else.
So anyway, you know, I
wish there were things
that I knew of that I
could take more action
other than just speaking out about it.
This transcends politics.
The only thing that I
can right now imagine
that is going to make a difference
is for there to be real accountability.
I think it's hard for anyone to imagine
a situation where this
shouldn't be held accountable
and you know, the whole theory of justice
is you might not capture every crime
or you might not be able to
hold everyone accountable,
but if there's at least
examples where people who
clearly did wrong are held accountable,
it can help create pause and keep others
from doing things in the future.
And obviously it shouldn't just be about
the people who directly committed it,
it should be the people
who also kind of let
some of this stuff go
by for many many years.
So anyway, I don't wanna pretend
that I'm a major actor in this,
but I did just wanna say
that this is something
that has unfortunately
it seems like we hear
stories about this every
three, four, five, six months
and they're disappointing,
but they just keep building on each other
and they're very very unfortunate
and just breaks your heart to see it
and it breaks your heart to think about
how many other situations
there might be like this
in the US and frankly around the world
where there's people in
groups who for whatever reason
don't have as much voice
and people who have more power
sometimes abuse that power.
And I wanna make it very clear,
there's many great wonderful
people in law enforcement.
I believe that the bulk
of people who desire
to go into law enforcement wanna do it
because they wanna protect society,
they wanna uphold the values
that we all believe in.
But there is I think more
than just a few bad apples
in that for sure in any field,
there might be people who get into wrong,
for the wrong reason, but
they should not be allowed
to act on it, especially when
they have the public's trust,
especially when they are armed,
especially when they can arrest folks
and physically manipulate, impact folks.
You have to have just a much much higher
standard of conduct and
a much higher standard
of what it means to hold
other people accountable
and not allow this type of thing to go on.
So anyway, I'll get off on my soap box.
This is a bother.
I'm fortunate, I haven't
directly experienced this
in my life but obviously
folks close to me have
and when you see things like this,
it really disturbs you.
But anyway, I'm happy to
look at questions, comments.
This is really just kind of
an open minded discussion.
I'd love ideas if folks might have.
Let's see.
A few folks are commenting
about my hair cut.
Thank you.
I mean, on a lighter note,
report about the hair cut situation is
I was so excited about the SpaceX launch
which I guess was a silver
lining from the weekend
that my wife wanted to give me a hair cut
and I was in such a hurry
I just took the clipper
from here and I did this.
But anyway, thanks for that comment.
I have mixed feelings about it,
but that was a highlight of the weekend
to see kind of what I think is
some of the best of humanity
when we work together,
the cool things that we can do together.
And I hope that I can on the livestream
bring some folks from
SpaceX at some point or NASA
to talk about that, but you know,
it's sad that the same society that can do
incredible things like
that on the same level,
we can't give basic human dignity
to large chunks of our population.
Let's see, other, there's comments.
I mean, there's a lot of good questions
and I'll just say, it just feels.
Normally I like answering
pretty much any question
that comes and some of
these are very flattering
to Khan Academy or to
me, but it just feels
a little bit beside the point right now.
And look, this crisis or
whatever we're going through
and obviously it's
layered on top of at least
one other large crisis,
it's not going to end today,
it's not going to end tomorrow,
but it is, this might be the thing
that finally makes this a major issue
that doesn't just get talked about
when there's another cell phone footage
of someone being abused or mistreated
or in this case killed for no other reason
than being in the wrong
place in the wrong time
with the wrong person.
But unfortunately we see a
little bit too much about that.
You know, this is a question
from Facebook related
to what we're seeing.
Mamta Bhattacharya, as an educator,
where should I start teaching
my students about racism?
You know, I don't wanna pretend
like I'm an expert at this,
so I can't really give
a lot of advice on it.
I would love advice
actually from other folks
on what, you know, if there's
ways that Khan Academy
or folks like us could
help, we'd love to know.
But I do have a general view that
the more exposure you have to folks
that are not like yourself
and the more appreciation
that children have or
people of all ages have
that frankly everyone on the planet
is pretty much just
normal people trying to
get on with their lives
and have basic health,
basic safety, basic education,
trying to do right by their children
and I've just pretty much
described almost everyone,
then hopefully we see a world where
some of this doesn't happen as much.
I'm someone who prides myself
in being able to empathize
and seeing both sides of an issue
or all three sides of an issue,
but I genuinely have
trouble getting in the minds
of folks who harbor the
degree of hate or anger,
irrational with no other, you know,
to be able to do these types of things.
There's no, there's been incidents before
that have been also atrocious,
but there's maybe there was fear,
maybe there was this or that,
but this is a situation
where you even if you're
grasping for straws, there's
no straws to grasp on
and all you can think of is
that it's pure hate, pure anger
and it's hard to understand that, frankly.
But yeah.
Let's see, from Facebook, I
wish I could be more helpful.
Deena Newman, we talked
with our kids about
having conversations with
people we are uncomfortable with
and ask questions and
hear stories to change
the narratives we already
have in our heads.
Great, so there you go.
To Mamta's question, Deena
has kind of answered it,
which is we have to be
comfortable in our discomfort
and that might be people
that we've stereotyped
in one way or the other
and it goes both ways.
I think we're in a time where
clearly a lot of African American folks
or minority folks might get stereotyped
and are treated unfairly
and you know there's,
this is a time where a
lot of very good people
who work in government or law enforcement
are also probably themselves
shaking their heads
and saying.
They're probably less
worried about themselves
and saying like, this is so unfortunate
that this is happening.
Because I mean, it's just so many layers.
Obviously the very act that it happens
and then there's the layer of
it just breaks down trust
and sometimes it might become harder
to have those conversations
that you're referring to
where folks can talk to people
who they might be initially
uncomfortable with
or who might feel like they
have a different life story
or life path than themselves.
So if there is a silver lining,
it's that this is kind of the straw
that breaks the camels back.
Real accountability's going to happen.
It's not just in Minneapolis,
but it's systematic real accountability
and I hope that the
energy just gets channeled
to more of these conversations
that you're talking about.
I think the protests
are an important part.
Obviously the peaceful protests are a very
important part of that.
I hope they continue
and the energy continues
and I hope over time
that energy also grows
and gets transferred into systemic change.
But I don't have a clear idea of
exactly how all of that plays out
but that can also be a hope.
Let's see, from Facebook, Alf,
for ideas on how to talk
to the white students,
you could read Raising White
Kids by Jennifer Harvey.
Students need to have these
difficult conversations.
Black lives matter in school is one model
for encouraging conversations
about race in school.
Thanks for that comment, Alf.
I don't know about this book so I can't
officially endorse it, but yeah,
I think it seems to go
into that same theme of
just more empathy and realizing that
as I said earlier, everyone's just trying
to live a decent life and it's really sad
when just, I tend to be an
American exceptionalist,
I tend to be very proud of many,
at least what the country
has attempted to stand for.
Obviously it's had its issues going back
to slavery and racism and the Civil,
I mean, we could go in.
I could say oh, well you
know, my family came to
this country after all of that happened,
but I'm a beneficiary of this country
and that means I'm also a
beneficiary of its history
and its history is not
perfect by any stretch
of the imagination and
so I think any of us,
even those of us who are immigrants
or who's family's immigrated here,
but we are able to
benefit from this country,
which I do love, also should feel,
should reflect on our
history of the country,
obviously reflect on the
history of where maybe
your roots are as where,
but also feel responsibility
to think about
how to change things because
a lot of that history
clearly has still a lot of,
probably more than we recognize.
There's a lot of stuff
going on that's still there.
So let's see.
Other things.
So Suchin Pollod, is this
actually the same Suchin
that I went to business school with?
Well if it is, well either way,
good to see you Suchin if
it's the Suchin I know.
It all starts at home.
How does one ensure we
are able to teach our kids
to walk a mile in someone else's shoes?
Empathy and kindness should be our focus
at home and in our schools.
Yep, couldn't agree more
whether you're the Suchin
that I know or a new Suchin.
I think you're the, I don't know how many
Suchin Pollod's there are in the world.
It's great to hear from you, Suchin.
But yeah, completely
agree and I think it is,
you know, it's intriguing.
I've talked to other nonprofits
that have been very focused on empathy
and empathy projects and I theorize hey,
wouldn't it be cool if there's
ways to get in the cloud
and volunteer and teach
kids who are in the,
quote, the other side of the
railroad tracks from yourself
or other side of the
country or in a country
that your country is at odds with
but you realize that the
people there are still people.
Yeah, I agree.
I think that's how empathy happens.
Let's see, Mahir Aray from Facebook says,
no one is born with hatred.
It's certain parts of our society
that inculcate such a thing and school is
the only place where we can remove this.
Yeah, I agree, I agree.
And I think, well you know, yeah.
I'm not an expert at any of this.
I'm just kind of thinking
live (laughing) about this
and for whatever it's worth.
So yeah, there's a lot of other questions
about Khan Academy and
normally I would really enjoy
answering all of these questions,
but given what's going on in the world,
I might take a pass at least for today.
I don't want us to kind of
stay mired in this forever,
but also don't wanna lose the energy there
and kind of just say,
oh this was unfortunate
and then move on and
then life is normal again
and then six months later it happens again
and then everyone says,
oh this is unfortunate,
how horrible and then life gets normal
and then six months
later, it happens again,
which is unfortunately been the pattern
for the last 20 or so years.
So yeah, that's.
I'll just maybe leave it at that for today
'cause you know, there's a
lot of good questions here
about Khan Academy and
education and all of that,
but I think for today's
episode of the livestream,
we'll just make it a little bit of this.
You know, this is just a
moment for all of us to pause,
all of us to think about
what kind of a society
we wanna be, what kind of
a country do we wanna be.
How does the justice system work,
how do we hold folks
accountable, and yeah,
and how do we not paint
folks with a broad brush
and treat everyone with dignity?
And I'll just leave it at that.
We're gonna have some interesting guests
for the next couple of days.
The CO of Naverisk, the mayor of San Jose.
I am going to ask them a few questions
about things like this.
I think they both have
an interesting viewpoint
and then we'll kind of continue
and talk about other things as well
like things like education, et cetera,
but obviously there's a lot of energy
as there should be around
what happened to George Floyd.
I have to say, there's
another dimension of this
that he's roughly my age
and so I don't know,
there's something about that
that you build even a
little bit more empathy
where you say, wow, what if that was me?
What if it's my children who are
because of some act of
cruelty or whatever?
And so anyway, I don't know.
Just stream of thought
consciousness from me.
My apologizes for not
being my chipper self.
But yeah, you know,
hopefully this pain leads
to some growth for us
as a society and you
know, not just in the US,
but around the world and it's all about
and it's not just about pointing fingers.
It's about looking at ourselves.
This happens in the US
we talk about red states
and blue states and we could easily say,
oh, this is happening
because people on that side
of the politics did this or didn't do that
and on this side, we're better,
but you know, I've seen
aspects of this happen
from people who vote either way.
I had actually another friend,
I won't use her name because I don't think
she's publicly talked about this
but this was actually
again in business school.
She was a Harvard student
and she was going into
her own apartment in Harvard Square
and the police accosted
her and arrested her
for thinking that she was
burglarizing her own apartment
and she was African American.
And so you know, these aren't random
and these are just kind of the things that
I've happened to see in
my own lifetime directly
and obviously you hear
the things on the news.
So yeah, let's just all
collectively think about
how we can not just feel upset about it
and not just talk about it,
but that the energy
continues beyond the moment
and it leads to real change
and real accountability
at a systemic level.
So with that, I'll let everyone go.
But thanks for joining this livestream
and my apologies for Marta.
We did the last minute change and I hope
to have Marta on again.
I think many of y'all
will enjoy talking to her
and we'll continue this conversation
and obviously it's connected to education
and empowerment, which is where
Khan Academy is focused on.
But thanks everyone for joining
and let's just hope, pray, meditate,
whatever you like to do
that we can find that
some good comes out of
what obviously is a
very unfortunate series
of situations and circumstances.
Talk to you all later.